Peter where do you see writers
struggling the most they don't
especially beginning writers don't
realize how long the process is going to
take that's that's really it
you know John Wells said I wish someone
had told me how long it was going to
take when I started being a writer and I
deal with a lot of beginners on one hand
and then we also deal with studio
writers on the other so I sort of see it
from both sides
but beginners think and maybe that's
good for them to think and I'm gonna
write this and in six months it's gonna
get sold and I'm gonna be famous and
maybe that energizes someone as a writer
and I'm all for that
but the truth is the average writer it
takes years and years yeah before your
first show is going to be bought let
alone put on now this is not a truth
that I think a lot of beginning writers
want to hear and I don't talk about it a
lot because it can be discouraging but
it isn't really if you think about it
the idea that you are going to write
something and sell it in six months is
is 99% of the time not true this is a
difficult craft it's a difficult art
it's just as hard as being a brain
surgeon maybe actually I think it's a
lot harder and so how long does it take
to be a brain surgeon right and then
you'll only come sometimes you'll have a
client say to me hey Peter I just want
to write one script so just give me a
little two-week course and that's like
saying hey you know what I want to do
just one brain surgery so just give me
the basics the brain surgery but this is
how people think I only know one guy who
sat down and wrote a script and it
became a big hit and immediately he was
a stand-up comic but 99.9% of the
writers who are who succeed it takes
years and so what do you do in those
years well you can be really unhappy
be and feel like you're a failure and
that's what most writers end up doing
right and they have other jobs and they
feel their numbers concede and their
parents tell them they're idiots and
their cousins laugh at them hey I've got
a house what are you still out there in
Hollywood haha you know what a loser so
the process and and the other idea is
that you know if you're over 22 as a
television writer your failed listen
every successful TV writer I know is in
his 30s or 40s often 50s so they won't
admit it because there's still that myth
but and there are a few they do hire
really guys and girls in their early 20s
and even below for certain youth
oriented shows but that's a slot most
writers most it takes at least 10 years
before you really get good at your craft
is that something you want to put on
your book when you're selling your book
no you know write your story you know in
ten years how about that right write a
script in ten years oh geez yeah I'm
gonna take that I'm gonna buy that book
just ten years great no it's right under
a week right or network your way right
there's a lot of people who sell the
idea of access right hey I'm gonna put
you in the same room with agents and
managers and that's all you need buddy
you just haven't been in the right room
okay they get in the room they hand them
the script the script sucks
they got no gig right so selling
accesses and I know and I think I said
this last year but it's bears repeating
if you write a good story people will
pound your door down to buy it you won't
have to worry about being represented
you don't have to worry about being in a
room with other people you will get your
stories sold if it's good conversely you
can have every connection in the world
and if your story's bad you're just
gonna get knows so patience and what's
Essie was talking about earlier with the
idea that you got to get comfortable
with the fact that you haven't got what
you want yet and you have to be at ease
and secure that you
vision is a good one I see the the level
of of surety and confidence I see in
almost every successful writer and some
of it's pathological I don't know that
it's been earned and maybe just sheer
narcissism but the level of confidence
that they have a story worth telling is
amazingly high this is part of their
success they simply don't stop they
continue to fail but they don't stop
that's the key you're gonna fail and
fail and fail
I think Churchill said success is the
ability to go from failure to failure
without losing your enthusiasm and I
really believe that's true especially in
Hollywood this is a difficult difficult
art it's a lot easier to be a doctor
it's a lot easier to be a lawyer go do
those things if you want to do that but
it's a ten year graduate program unless
you're William Shakespeare there's like
0.01% of people this doesn't apply to
I've never met them I've never run into
them as a story consultant everybody I
know and I know and worked with a lot of
very successful writers they all took at
least ten years
you